[Musique]
ce
matin j'ai tourné une scène des preuves
qui se rapproche vraiment des scènes des
preuves classique marque oui vous serez
avec marina et soraya
effectivement aujourd'hui on tourne la
chasse au trésor pour aller trouver une
femme et ses collègues qui va ouvrir un
fameux coffre dans lequel il y aura un
fameux sombrero qui va nous donner
l'immunité et n'aura le droit d'aller
dans un village typique donc un monde du
mexique pour s'hydrater manger et on
sait bien que manger et voir dans ce
genre de jeu c'est quand même essentiel
3 2 1
je pense que l'un des plus gros défi
pour le flambeau par rapport aux
épreuves c'était vraiment que ce soit
crédible que ce soit réaliste vous allez
passer à la mythique épreuve des
flambeaux c'est une course relais en
cette étape j'ai vraiment une conception
une réflexion sur les épreuves pour que
ce soit le plus crédible possible sans
sont copiés d'autres épreuves qui
existait ailleurs sur d'autres éditions
avec en amont vraiment des croquis qui
ont été faites très précis sur le type
d'épreuve qui aurait lieu est vraiment
avec une conception avec l'équipe déco
donc ça a été vraiment en danger
et
puis oui l'enjeu de faire ça dans l'eau
avec toutes les contraintes conseil de
tournai est ce que c'est que de tourner
dans l'eau avec une équipe ça peut être
très compliqué
vous êtes
très vite aussi on a décidé de partir
autres par hi hi hi de laisser libre
cours à des fantasmes encore plus dingue
des épreuves qui peuvent pas normalement
avoir lieu là dedans il de faire un mix
encore plus fou que si on avait mélangé
que des émissions du même genre il ya
une cargaison de drogue qui arrivent sur
l'île il ya un gars qui veut récupérer
sa drogue vous allez fabriquer la farine
et ce sera l'épreuve du jour ça a été
une émission de cuisine un tout petit
peu spéciale avec la farine manutan la
williams il a l'air bien d'avancer la
merde fait chier faut que j'accélère pas
car sinon ça devient du crack clou du
film cocaïne gurman je vais le faire
voyager l'épreuve de fin qui s'appelle
l'épreuve des décors d'eau avec des
supplices évidemment pour les faire
déstabiliser donc voilà c'est ça voilà
on a adapté sa notre univers quant à
l'enjeu qui suit est d'une simplicité
diabolique puisqu'il s'agit du stress el
sol 1 2 3 soleil pour récupérer de la
batterie de portable qu'on n'oserait el
sol on a fait un deux trois soleil une
fois
45 ans est jamais trop tard alors la
révélation c'est william rond net a
presque points 50 cm du tap m
prenez sur le making-of de la fin de
saison deux semaines avec squeeze c'est
par action
ce quiz y est arrivé moi je le
connaissais pas et tout mais pareil je
voyais très bien qui s'était jamais et
j'aime bien gouttes les gars du tube cd
très bon gars
allaient bien fait photo ap les deux
hommes si ces faits là et c'est des mecs
en hausse et des tafurs des mecs d'une
généreuse des fautes plutôt que j'y
retrouve autant contre et j'ai le droit
de dire tu es mon candidat préféré make
way d'où ses collègues
je pense être aussi je crie ça et
william quand j'ai appelé l'agent
squeeze truc très vite on s'est parlé il
a dit oui très vite il est venu il était
trop content de faire ça et il a trop
bien fait
que souhaitez-vous faire williams
récupérer ce téléphone rester dans le
jeu ou rejoindre ce qu'on me dit
[Rires]
ce coup-ci ce téléphone je perds en fait
à l'épreuve du 1 2 3 soleil parce qu'en
fait j'ai une tentation à l'éradiquer
la donation est énorme puisque je vois
squeeze et le dieu de williams et donc
c'est soit g 20 minutes de téléphone
soit j'ai une photo avec squeeze et
bahia est le dilemme non il n'a pas
finalement parce que c'est la photo
avant tout s'entend fait preuve
j'écoutais liste s'il vous plaît vous
pouvez prendre la photo je le sais plus
et non williams si vous aviez voulu un
téléphone il aurait fallu gagner
l'épreuve or vous voulez la faire
poser délégation du mouvement
mois ces deux gars se connaissent très
bien et c'était génial que l'autre soit
fan de thua de l'un de l'autre quoi donc
c'était assez génial je côtoie un jour
tu seras jamais au dessus de ma fille tu
seras pour community manager tu seras
jamais au dessus de moi
[Musique]